I am a homeschooler trying to play
sports at high levels to get into
college I'm seeing all of these players
that I've competed with for years and
years and years succeeding and taking
the steps that they need to to chase
after their dreams and you know I'm
sitting here frustrated knowing that I
can't because the attempt to bill didn't
pass the tim tebow bill would allow
homeschooled students to participate in
public schools sports teams this long
ongoing issue has been split fairly down
the middle throughout the country my
name is caleb Carter
I just turned 17 so I've been
homeschooled for five years it's my
style of learning much better and gave
me more freedom with the subjects that I
wanted to learn we had established that
we definitely wanted to move forward
with homeschooling because he was
thriving in that environment so the next
problem was how does he play soccer it
became an issue
Caleb's ninth grade year when everyone
started playing for their high school
team and then he didn't have a place to
play when we first began homeschooling
that's one of the questions you get
asked what about sports the Tim Tebow
act is something in West Virginia that
has been on the table and in discussions
for almost a decade it was basically a
piece of legislation that allowed
homeschooled students private school
students access to extracurricular
activities that are offered through the
public school system it actually passed
both the Senate and the House a few
years ago and then it was vetoed by
Governor Jim Justice there's just not as
many opportunities for children to eat
to exercise those skills and to be a
part of team athletics
I am the only home schooler all my
travel team right now all of the travel
players that I'm playing with right now
play for their school they are training
five times a week with multiple games
and each week I try to run as much as I
can I try to do as much fitness as I can
but you know it's still so much
different when you're talking about in
game I did not play for any school or
travel team in the fall for my freshman
year and that was the longest break that
I've ever taken since I was four from
play soccer you can't represent
something that you're not part of so if
there's a name on your shirt you go to
that school you're representing that
school we try not to separate the sports
perspective from the school that if
you're a homeschool student you're
breaking the number-one rule that says
you must be enrolled in that school I
have a son he's a really good pitcher
and he missed out on those 11th and 12th
grade years of being able to play any
organized sports so watching him grow up
without that opportunity has really
motivated me to be on top of things with
the Tim Tebow act the home schoolers
aren't going to come in and take
positions from public school players who
deserve them home schoolers live in
those districts I still pay taxes for
all of these schools but my child is not
allowed to go participate nowhere in our
rule book does tax ever come up it never
says if you pay taxes you get to
participate people don't own a car don't
own a house maybe on some sort of
subsidy they don't pay taxes at all but
if they come to school they're enrolled
in that school then they get to
participate if they meet all other
eligibility requirements there's a large
number of homeschool students in West
Virginia
if all those kids start participating
then there could be an additional cost
to each County I mean I think when we
went to the virtual school we've
compromised
[Music]
there might be people who are using
virtual school and are having success
with it that doesn't mean it's the
answer to our dilemma I don't know of
any parent who has pursued virtual
school more than one year are you guys
familiar with the Tebow legislation for
home schoolers good my son pitched his
last game the summer before his 10th
grade year I know it's heartbreaking we
tested in 2017 and Jim Justus vetoed it
saying that the virtual school now was
the solution but what we're saying is
it's not the solution it wasn't the
solution for 24 other states nice to
meet you what was your name again I
think that the homeschooling parents in
West Virginia overwhelmingly have the
best intentions for their children and
so when we look at the coursework that's
even offered through Virtual School
you're asking families to sacrifice a
curriculum that they've designed for
their child specifically I just don't
think West Virginia needs to ask us to
sacrifice that there's a group of
homeschool parents who don't want
anything to do with the virtual and I
think if you're making a choice that we
don't want to be connected to the public
school then it's hard for me to say okay
you can't be connected but we ought to
let you play athletics for or
extracurricular activities for that same
public school
I was one of the first students to try
the virtual school I tried it in my
freshman year what we were told
initially was not the way the program
ended up being he ended up having to go
to the school three to four times a week
because they wouldn't allow him to take
even quizzes without being proctored by
someone at the school closest to us so I
started my enrollment in private school
part time in my sophomore year and the
reason that I'm wanting a change from
the private school is because they don't
get the exposure that I needed to get
recruited by college
my dream college that I would go to
would be Ohio State for the only time
that a coach or recruiter from my host
agency me is when I'm at a college
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't really know what I'm going to do
about soccer next year if the Tim Tebow
bill would get passed then it would
solve so many problems for me
17 Republicans voted no I didn't hear
he's not here anymore
but anyways so these are the ones you
need to work on okay some of these can
easily be swayed but if you look at what
our boat total was we weren't far away
lastly I'm just gonna be very blunt
about it this is about money otherwise
they wouldn't make the virtual school
argument they would say we want you in
our school site if this passes will the
sky fall in the next two years will we
see this influx that's crazy the SSC
can't for him if they see can't handle
what's going on no you're actually gonna
see a small percentage I mean very small
percentage and even then that small
percentage are just going to be the
people who are trying out we as the ssac
in our member schools and the homeschool
community need to work through resolve
this you know this needs to be resolved
by us the parties who are involved and
if we have to go back to the legislature
it's going to be a fight a ten year
fight again I don't know anyone who is
well versed in history who says you get
what you get you don't throw a fit and
think that that is sufficient for the
American culture we're Americans we
fight for freedoms and that's what
homeschooling parents are doing through
the Tim Tebow legislation all of the
players that are on his travel team
right now in the fall they go to play
with their schools knowing his passion
for the game and knowing how much time
and effort he gives and then having to
watch him not be able to go out there
and play and have these experiences is
really heartbreaking
[Music]
you